hello everybody today i'm going to give
you some insights
in the linguistic assistance competition
this is an ast-1 competition
meaning it's an entry-grade level
competition for
recruiting assistance this time
we're looking for linguistic assistance
in six languages they're mentioned on
this screen here
so we're looking for people in estonian
croatian italian dutch
polish and portuguese
as an applicant you can only choose one
language or you can only apply for
one language competition
you may have seen on the website this
infographic giving you in a nutshell an
overview of the different stages of this
competition
and today in the next few minutes i will
be giving you some more insights in the
different steps
of this competition
so let's first have a look at the
eligibility criteria
for an ast-1 competition you need either
a post-secondary
degree
relevant to the nature of the duties
or you need secondary education plus
three years of professional experience
in the field
now what does a linguistic assistant do
you see the duties mentioned here as
well
these people assist linguists linguists
being translators or loyal linguists for
instance
they would perform duties
using translation tools
you may know that these days machine
translating is very helpful
in the job of a translator
they would support training as well they
would ensure document management and
manage linguistic information as well so
that's in a nutshell what linguistic
assistance will do
apart from the degree
there's also of course a language
criterion
the first language must be one of the
six competition languages
which you must master on excellent level
so c2 level
and the second language must be either
english or french and there you need at
least a b2 level
the selection procedure has as you can
see here four stages if you want first
there will be the application then there
are two testing stages and then the last
stage is the
publication of the reserve list which
leads to recruitment
and in this presentation i will give you
some insights again
in these different steps
everything starts with the creation of
an epso account so if you do not have
one yet you can create one on our
website
i just remind you that you can only have
one epso account for all your epso
applications do not create new accounts
for new competitions that you want to
take part in
you can then apply through our website
of course and you can't fill in or you
have to fill it fill in
the application form
within the deadline
deadline is 24th of may midday brussels
time
and you can
fill out your application in any of the
24 official eu languages
everybody who applies will be invited to
the first stage of testing which is a
set of multiple choice questions
first we test your reasoning skills your
verbal numerical and abstract reasoning
skills
and then we also test your language
comprehension
in your language one and two
and you see in this frame here the
number of questions you get the time
allocated to solve these questions and
the points you can
win
with these questions
as you can see you need to have a
combined pass mark for your reasoning
skills tests
and you need at least 7 out of 12 for
each of your language comprehension
tests
a language comprehension test is a test
to
assess your linguistic abilities
in terms of vocabulary grammar syntax
syntax and style of a text
in the link or on the link through the
link on this slide you will find sample
tests for all of this so please do
have a look at these reasoning skills
and language comprehension tests that we
make available on this page
because by training this by rehearsing
this
your results will improve you will get
better at performing
when you see the real test by having a
look at these sample tests they are
available in all languages
the best ones after testing stage one
will be invited to testing stage two and
there we first test your general
competencies you see seven competencies
being tested
through two different tests
the case study is a written exercise
we'll test four competencies you see
them listed here
and then an interview will test
three more general competencies
for each competency you can gain up to
10 points
and you need again at least a combined
pass mark of 35 out of 70. okay
after testing these general competencies
you will also have to sit a test to
test your field related competency and
for this competition we
have designed a test which we call
finalization of a text
which basically means that you will be
given
a source text
in
language two so either english or french
you're
choosing and then you will get the
translation of the of that text and this
text will contain mistakes
uh both in formatting and in language
and then of course the candidate has to
detect and correct
the mistakes in the text so that it
matches the source text of course all
right
as you can see this is quite a heavy
test it lasts one hour and you can gain
up to 100 points which are of course
very important to make it to the list of
successful candidates so the people
having the highest marks on both the
field-related competency and the general
competencies
will be listed on the list of successful
candidates
which is the basis for recruitment and
in this slide you see the number of
people that we are selecting for each of
the languages
the next step is then recruitment
uh the recruiting bodies will search
this list when they have vacancies and
offer jobs to the people on the list
the objective is to recruit everybody in
the year to come now the initial
validity of the reserve list is three
years
so not everybody of course will be
offered a job straight after publication
of this list some people will have to
wait a little longer
if you have more questions on this
i advise you to read very carefully the
notice of competition which is the legal
document very extensive document
explaining you all these steps much more
in detail than what i've shared with you
now
if you would still have questions you
can always reach out to us through our
contact form on the website
so and you can also follow us on
facebook and linkedin twitter and
instagram of course to keep or to stay
updated on news that we have on this and
other competitions
also check out the other videos
available on this youtube channel you'll
find out much more on different profiles
we select star for you'll find
testimonials of people currently working
in different positions in the
institutions
so
this is what i want to share with you
about this competition
good luck to the ones who want to apply
and hopefully i see you next
in a following video bye